more than one and one-half million
citizens of the united states claim
spanish as their mother tongue they are
a happy spirit in the face of toil and
hardship enriches our land they bear
more than their share of the crushing
burden of tuberculosis this story is
dedicated to them in the hope that it
will speed the day when our all nations
shall be freed of man's ancient enemy
tuberculosis
you see dr. they are a very happy people
they're old customs their own length all
of these things mean so much to them
they work hard it is true but they
certainly do enjoy themselves they
surely do enjoy themselves
my real estate I've got to be going
you'd end up by
father what it is your mother
mother had one of her coughing spells
blood came from a mouth father's in
there
why don't you eat my child I'm not
hungry father you are sick no don't you
worry
I am going with child I can help it
she's your mother left awesome a year
ago you have been coughing you don't eat
you feel tired I have watched you untied
yes very absurd i'm gonna be funny well
you see I see nothing it hasn't rained
in so long discussed in the road some of
the coming months rose I won't have you
worry about me I'm all right play you
have to get up early to go to work good
night there's no
thar she why it's not the work and how
she caught just saw you behind my dear
Consuelo I have seen you praying peace
and consolation are the blessings that
our blessed mother gives to her children
Travis I'm afraid my mother was taken
from us and now i am a oh my god I'm
tired all the time I had the same size
as she had help me Father help me yes
Consuelo I will help you i will give you
the blessings of church and all the
consolations of religion but you must
take my advice you must go to a doctor
at once he
and he will help you
you must not use patent medicines you
must not use home remedies God has made
us to understand and to know he has
given us an intelligence he has also
given us science and the doctors spend
their lives curing and helping those who
are you and who saw God wants us to use
the gifts that he has given us from
heaven you must go to a doctor and swell
well now let's see now
now come along and me
step up young many weeks with your team
this wonderful x-ray light goes right
through your body and makes a picture of
the inside of your chest on the film
that we can see if any damage has been
done to your loan with the ear we hear
the sounds in the lung true but the
picture is even better and more exact
with the x-ray we can now find
tuberculosis in the early stage before
there are any other side step side
things
you know Consuelo if I had my way about
it every young person no matter how well
he may be would be x rated that may come
someday we do not know enough of this
world pero if I only would take
consuelos mother to the doctor but we
are afraid of doctors also we know
nobody tells that is what we think but
it is not you men and women go around
telling us about the Cygnus they try to
explain but do we listen them oh we did
not even pay attention basil I know so
well the symptoms her mother had them
too oh I am so so so afraid I must say
this is a good way to attend you jump
man my supposed to entertain move what
why not he's going to be around the
house if either marry him that sounds
like my Consuelo give it to him never
allow a man to be too sure you look
better I think a doctor had helped you
already but don't forget she will tell
me tomorrow all about how you wrong low
syllabus all this is healthy long but
they're a shadow like a little cloud in
the sky that means trouble beginning in
the lung I suspected
like mama like daughter no no
tuberculosis is not imperative it is
passed from one person to another now
let me show you what I mean
sit down
the germs that cause tuberculosis grow
in the lungs of the person who has a
disease the germs are very small whoever
comes close to the mouth of the person
who has tuberculosis it's likely to pick
up some of the germs and once the germs
are in the mouth of a healthy person
they may find their way into the lung
this is how the seed of tuberculosis is
planning a mother kissing her child a
sneeze or a call sleeping together sick
people spit on the ground a child later
picks up the germs on his fingers and
carries them to his mouth a sick person
can be healed but in the meantime he
spreads the disease too many other
persons with whom he comes in contact if
he is cared for in a sanatorium his
diseases cannot spread what what can I
do we will send Consuela to a sanatorium
and there she will get well yes I have
seen them they are beautiful but we are
poor those places are for rich people
not what people like claws no no
therefore all all people in an
enlightened community know that
tuberculosis is not only a personal
misfortune but that it threatens every
household tuberculosis knows no line of
race religion or social status so people
gladly support a sanatorium knowing that
there by their own children will be
protected that sounds reasonable but can
my Consuelo be taken to such a place
certainly I will have one of the nurses
of the Health Department come to you and
make arrangements to take Consuelo to
the sanatorium thank you doctor never
mind but there is one more thing one and
Maria must be examined also tuberculosis
in its early stages is without symptoms
so don't forget to bring them here I
will
tuberculin test first and if that shows
that the germs are in their bodies then
they too must be x-rayed
didn't hurt
everybody's talking about you and your
daughter is she really one of us a
notorious yes and how did you do it I
listen I'm dead what the doctor told me
I think you saw your soul to the table
what do you mean I know how to make
people do what you want him to do oh
that this is actually what I did you
mean that course not you are the most
inner and men I ever so I listened and I
learn that is it rolled with you you are
ignorant and won't learn you're just as
ignorant as I am what you can learn I
gotta learn to see you all group six
feet on the floor of all rotten things
to do we spit on the floor you don't
bail what is the matter with you love it
I see what I like so do you I do not I
know better let me show what the doctor
explained to me I have a book and I want
you to see it you say oh come on it's
really going to be well again of course
she's looking splendid she's getting
stronger every day every day miss oldies
certainly why do you ask she's back to
sanatorium for nearly a year that's it
all day she sure must be powerful strong
by now one usually how all figured out
how do you do nurse you are so nice to
come so often well I had to look after
all of you controlling the doctor always
asks about children are doing fine fresh
air good food plenty of rest fresh
vegetable you see we grow them ourselves
that's fine miss little bit the doctor
asked me to remind you however that it's
been nearly a year since Juan and Maria
or examined
he wants you to bring the mini-game
certain but would you mind to come to my
home and tell me how he's much wisdom
that's a good girl well you'll be going
home soon aren't you going of course but
no but oh I don't know how I can
psychology Oh yo yo yo oh isn't that
nice I want it all to be my second but
water comes a la la see ya later on the
air legally knows my shame over so I can
it just a lotta move on de la sierra
morena cielito Lindo PNM ba condo par de
tous narrow cielito lindo de fondo oh
you're
gone I know your head what okay come
bumble see aliens here lethal in two
years have passed since you left the
sanatorium you have been a good girl I
find that the longest well he you now
you may marry but remember that now
as long
remember doctrine last time we were here
how I remarked to you that these are
very happy people and now i am a very
healthy
okay you'll get one
una Rosa he wanted a boy haha
you